in order to move us along here i am
going to introduce catherine Haslam see
far associate fellow professor in
clinical psychology at the University of
Queensland and Martin Garber Conrad our
community responded who's the CEO of the
Edmonton Community Foundation and he's
been there since 2005 their BIOS are in
your programs so rather than read them
out to you we'll just invite Kathryn to
the podium thank you very much Thank You
Tara and I'd also like to thank you all
for giving us the opportunity to come
out here and talk about our work when
Alex and I left Brisbane the
temperatures were fluctuating around the
mid 30 degrees so hitting Edmonton at
minus 20 was was a bit of a shock to the
system but I'm looking forward to the
social connections that we develop here
through our discussions in our
networking to buffer me in my challenge
to acclimatize so in my presentation I
want to extend on Alex's talk to focus
more specifically on how the social
identity approach actually can drive our
interventions the interventions that can
aim to protect health and well-being and
in doing so in this presentation I have
two main points that I want to make
about interventions first it's only the
social group interventions that create a
sense of belonging that create a sense
of connectedness and shape our identity
that actually bring health and
well-being benefits and we've
demonstrated this in a number of
intervention studies that we've that
we've conducted and these these this
slide or these images just illustrate
the themes of those interventions and I
want to focus on just a couple of those
interventions in my talk today just to
give you a bit of a feel for what they
can look like and what outcomes they can
generate and second for groups to
actually function as a psychological
resource we need to actually be able to
know how to access and use them
effectively now social we know that
social relationships aren't that easy to
come by
for people who are more vulnerable due
to mental illness social exclusion
discrimination and economic hardship
people in that position often find that
they've had fewer positive social group
experiences and also feel less confident
in how to use those social groups to
help them now we it was it was in
response to this and other related
questions that we recently developed an
intervention which we refer to as groups
for health and the whole idea of groups
for health is to actually tackle this
particular issue to try and skill people
up so that they can access and use their
social groups effectively and so in the
second part of my talk I do want to
spend a little bit of time talking about
what groups for health actually
comprises and to give you some days for
on its efficacy so as you've already
heard from alex social identity approach
is quite useful in helping us understand
how and why social groups protect our
health and build our resilience but it
also is a very useful framework and
provides us with a number of lessons to
guide intervention so one of the strong
messages that's actually advocated in
the framework is the importance of
creating strong positive group
relationships to build that virtual
circle of social identification that you
saw earlier but importantly those
relationships and those group
relationships must be meaningful any
group intervention must have or any
group that a person actually takes
planning must have value must be valued
by the people who are taking part and
also have purpose if they're going to
shape people's identity and also
influence how they feel about themselves
and second group up the the framework
also shows us and recognises the groups
are like a double-edged sword not all
groups are good for us and in our
interventions what we aim to do is to
create relationships that are curative
ones that are based on cooperation trust
and mutual support and try and avoid
those harmful relationships that are
based on exploitation mistrust and
humiliation now I want to we've used
these
lessons and guidelines among others to
drive our interventions and inform our
interventions and the two interventions
that I want to describe to you now are
interventions that we've conducted with
seniors living in the community
receiving supported Care Bear or
receiving supported care in residential
homes and these two interventions that
I'm going to be focusing on I've chosen
because they can be readily adapted to a
range of different contexts and
different populations as you'll see
these interventions had very different
content but had the same basic aim of
trying to build people's sense of
connectedness and through that shape
their identity so this first
intervention was a field study that we
conducted that I refer to as our design
team study and this field study was
actually developed in response to a
concern that was raised by a manager
over care home the organization that we
were working with she was concerned that
residents in her home were becoming a
bit more isolated so the home was
structured with a central hub the
central hub had a main dining room in
the lounge and around that central hub
were wings we're up to six residents
actually resided something like small
neighborhoods and within those wings was
a wing lounge and it was that lounge
that wasn't being used and the reason
why the manager was concerned that
people might be coming isolated from
there from their neighbors so our
solution was to create a new meaningful
wing group to facilitate that sense of
connection amongst residents and to this
end we developed encouraged or created a
series of design teams where residents
were responsible for redecorating their
wing lounge now we had 24 residents from
that care home who actually took part in
this study but because this study was
also partly filmed for a BBC one program
television program we also recruited
another 12 residents from the same
organization living in a similarly
structured care home who basically just
received care as usual and no filming
so these 24 residents were randomly
assigned to either be members of a
design team where they were given a
palette of materials pictures plants and
a feature wall color to redecorate their
wing lounge and you can see here an
image of a one of the design teams
actually in the process of negotiation
the remainder were assigned to have
staff redecorate their lounge which is
basically business as usual in care
facilities where staff will actually
sort of perform make some of these
decisions and here is a team of staff
who are actually involved in this and
they were given the same palette of
materials to work with and those 12 the
other 12 residents from another home
were basically basically received no
redecoration and care as usual now prior
to and after this intervention we took a
number of measures and the ones that I'm
going to be highlighting today here is
people sense of identification with
others on the in their wing their sense
of well-being cognitive integrity or
intellectual fitness if you like and
also given the managers concern the use
of the lounge were they participating
and using that lounge and socially
active within that space so the data
that you see here the lines in in pink
relate to the design team people taking
part as design team members line in blue
was where staff performed the
redecoration and the dotted line is
where there was no change and what you
can see quite clearly here is that it
was only those members of the design
team people who took part in
redecorating their own wing wing lounges
who actually had an enhanced sense of
connection with the people living on
their wing and this was associated with
other benefits it was associated with
enhanced life satisfaction enhanced
cognitive integrity but also
particularly for the design team members
here a three-fold increase in their use
of space now there's an interesting side
story to this that the manager shared
after the study was completed now in the
process of filming every
he was quite tired it takes a bit it
takes quite a bit out of you staff and
residents were pretty exhausted after
that after the after that after that
process and it was on that final day of
filming that one of the residents
actually went missing and the staff
phoned the manager who was beside
herself with worry wondering whether she
should have initiated this had she
pushed her staff and residents too far
should she have even taken part in this
study so she asked the staff to perform
one last check before thinking about
phoning the police and in the process of
that final check the staff made one
final check of the residents room and to
access the room this time they actually
switched on the light to the wing lounge
before entering her room and there they
saw this resident sitting in the corner
comfortably smiling to herself admiring
the work that she and her fellow design
team members had actually performed
earlier that day so the manager actually
did admit to feeling incredibly relieved
upon that news but also had admitted
that she got what she wished for in
droves but the very next day she also
started planning with her staff how to
create design teams for the rest of her
her the residents living in in the home
so that they could actually be open to
these opportunity to the opportunity of
receiving these benefits so if I can go
on to the next study and the next field
study as you'll see is very different to
to the design team study and this one
actually focused on trying to enhance
people's sense of social connectedness
through use of social media and in this
study we were working with seniors who
are both living in the community but
also seniors who are receiving care and
in a home and they're already anybody
who's familiar with this literature
knows that there is a wealth of evidence
already out there of work that's being
conducted looking at where the social
media can enhance
the connectedness of seniors and the
date is pretty mixed and in fact quite a
few of the studies show no change as
with integration of social media or
using social media our thinking on this
was that there wasn't that much
investment in those studies on helping
people to use social media as a resource
and so that's what we decided to do in
this particular study was to actually
provide a three month training program
to help people who were novices in using
computers and using social media as to
how to actually use it as as a resource
so our participants here were 76 seniors
and you can see their partner status
here and all those people living in the
community most of them were living alone
these seniors were randomly assigned to
receive care as usual or what we refer
to as the easy PC intervention and easy
PC is a is a is a computer platform that
was developed by the care or IT people
working in the care organization that
supported this study and it basically
you can see you can see the image of you
can see the image of the platform down
here which basically is a simpler
simpler display screen few icons that
are larger and this also contained a
touch screen for ease of access hence
the reason for referring to this as easy
PC and our social media training with
this platform actually involved helping
people in trialing use of email Skype
Facebook and in some cases it extended
to chat rooms now prior to and after the
intervention our measures here focused
on social network activity people's
health and well-being but also we're
interested here in the mechanisms but
through which the training might have
actually enhanced health so you can see
here the data and it's pretty clear if
you look at the red bars here for the
people who received easy PC training
it's it's the training that's actually
resulting in an increase in people
social network activity and we're also
seeing enhance many people's cognitive
performance here and this is pretty
pretty consistent with the qualitative
feedback that we
saved from participants and also their
family members with people saying that
they're now having better relations with
groups of others such as their family
but also people indicating that they've
gray gained greater confidence in using
social media no longer being a
technophobe now we were also
particularly interested in the
mechanisms or the pathways through which
training might have actually enhanced
these outcomes and you can see here our
outcomes of cognitive performance mental
health and quality of life what we found
was that the training didn't directly
influence all of these outcomes but it
did so indirectly through building
people's sense of personal identity
their sense of string it strengthened
their understanding of who they were and
this was enhanced through processes of
increasing people's competence and
confidence in using using social media
but also through expanding their social
networks through these pathways there
was enhancement in people's sense of who
they were and that in turn influenced
influenced health and well-being
outcomes in a positive way so again what
you're seeing here is that these
combination of social networks and
identification or what seems to be
driving very clearly these health
outcomes now these group activities and
other group activities that we've
conducted we certainly do believe
provide an important solution but I
think it's important to to be explicit
in saying that simply offering any group
activity isn't going to be a recipe for
success and there are a couple of
reasons for this first because groups
need to have meaning and value to bring
health gains then these are going to
have to change as people's motivations
and interests change across their life
so a group that might be important for
you at one point in your life may be
less important in the future and when
they have when they lose that importance
they also lose their protective power
and secondly
We certainly have data from our
colleagues who are working with homeless
populations showing that a single
positive group experience is an
important stepping stone even after
multiple negative social experiences but
the evidence is that its social capital
that it's belonging to multiple groups
that are important to you that actually
bring the greater health gain so one
group is important but it's not
sufficient we certainly need more and it
was in thinking about these issues and
trying to generate a longer-term
solution that we recently developed our
groups for health now groups for health
is a social identity driven intervention
the targets specifically social
isolation so the whole aim of this
program is to give people the education
and the skills that they need in order
to be able to manage and engineer their
own social environments independently in
the long-term so the intervention itself
is manualized and it comprises five
modules that we loosely refer to as the
5 s's and that will become it'll become
everything in a moment why I refer to
them as the 5 s's so our first module of
schooling is essentially educational and
the whole point of fest is to raise
people's awareness of the value of
groups for health something that a lot
of lot of us take for granted and also
of ways that we can actually harness
those groups our second module of
scoping aims to increase people's
awareness of the social of this of the
social relationships they have and
potentially gaps in those relationships
now we developed a social identity
mapping tool to facilitate this process
so that ultimately what's developed is a
map that's illustrated for people that
shows what their social world looks like
now and we use this as a basis for
getting people to think about what their
ideal social worlds might look like in
our third module of sourcing this module
aims to train people with the skills
that they need to maintain and use their
groups existing groups most effectively
but also to try and re contact any
groups that that might have dropped off
recently
for whatever reason our fourth module of
scaffolding uses the intervention group
as a platform for people to develop new
connections so groups for health is a
new group and hopefully a new positive
group experience for people who are
taking part and giving them the
experience of actually using some of
those skills that they can scaffold in
terms of trying to develop some new
connections now we run these weekly and
our final module of sustaining is
conducted a month later and the whole
idea of that month is to give people
some time to trial out some of their
plans that they developed to see whether
they can actually develop some new
connections and to bring back their
experiences and also to have an
opportunity to troubleshoot and to
revisit their social network identity
maps now we've recently trialed this in
our psychology clinic at the University
of Queensland and the people who took
part in this were people who were
screened for depression and social
isolation and presented with at least
mold problems in these areas and these
are data from the people who completed
you can see quite clearly hear that the
intervention is actually reducing
anxiety stress depression and loneliness
across the board but particularly
pleasing for us is this result here with
the multiple group membership actually
showing us that the program was
achieving its aim of helping people to
develop more connections as a
consequence of taking part in this
intervention and particularly pleasing
as well was the fact that those games in
people's group membership predicted
their health and well-being outcomes so
this just the figure here just shows you
the the data for depression and what you
can see here in the red line is that it
was only among those people who made
gains in their group memberships who
actually experienced a reduction in
their symptoms of depression and our
process data was positive as well so
people were certainly indicating that
they learned from the program and that
they will use the techniques that they'd
learned through the program in the few
so I just have a couple of points in
closing I think there's no doubt and I
think we all agree that health has a
social dimension but I think we need to
start moving away from thinking about
health as a problem solidly residing in
individuals often we're much better off
thinking about solutions for the health
of managing for managing the health of
neighborhoods and communities and the
beauty of the social identity approach
is it provides us with a framework to
understand that social dimension but it
also provides us with some guidelines
how we can as to how we can use social
groups as a psychological resource in
the context of intervention and finally
if we want to have the greatest impact
all of this work needs to be translated
into identity centered policies because
we know it's only at that higher level
that we're going to benefit and reach
more of the at-risk groups that we work
with thank you for
in the community sector the value of
social group interaction was expressed
with particular clarity almost exactly
20 years ago with publication of Robert
putnams Bowling Alone we know how
important civically engaged communities
are to democracy and indeed to health
the value of social networks two people
working and living in communities is
evident should we be surprised that
social involvement is also important
when people are elderly ill or
marginalized perhaps even more so
professor Haslam has demonstrated and
communicated clearly and forcefully that
group interventions can create a sense
of belonging and bring concrete health
benefits she has outlined some of the
factors that distinguish good group from
bad group and has highlighted a
particularly significant characteristics
of groups that are more health enhancing
namely group relationships and
activities that are meaningful that have
value and purpose I was particularly
taken with the design team project in
care homes not only did the intervention
participants perceive the experience
positively but they demonstrated
improved cognitive functioning what
struck me is even more telling is that
the actual use of the lounge they helped
design increased the computer training
experiment was also compelling and I
think bodes well for the future as more
of our aging population has some
familiarity already with computers in
the internet it should make training
easier and perhaps increase the capacity
for more sophisticated activities
hacking North Korea perhaps you know
anyway and although I personally don't
see the appeal of Facebook and all those
all those other sites the teens use
instead now that their parents have
discovered facebook and made it
so uncool I can certainly see the value
of virtual social relationships of the
sort that I maintain with old-fashioned
email and hope to continue as my
mobility decreases and face-to-face
friends thin out in any case professor
Haslam has done us a considerable
service by providing solid evidence of
the value of these interventions not
only to feelings of well-being but to
more concrete health benefits like
cognitive performance and mitigation of
depression and finally she has reminded
us that like many health enhancing
interventions they work best when
multiplied and continued over the long
term recognizing the value of this new
evidence I would also suggest that in
practice in the community these kinds of
interventions are not entirely new the
area with which I most familiar is
housing for people with mental illnesses
and other challenges although not
excluding medical interventions like
drugs and talk more than one housing
program we design place particular
emphasis on social group interventions
particularly ones that had meaning for
the residents at least part of that
meaning resulted from an external
community service focus rather than
bringing health services into the
facility residents were encouraged to
reach out into the community for the
health and social services that were
already there and I think this is the
crucial part and to give back by
themselves providing meaningful service
to others in the community maintaining
the neighborhood rink for example
staffing the neighborhood cleanup day in
fact even the project service providers
provided services also to the community
as I recall guitar lessons were one of
the favorites we are so fortunate now to
have
this sound evidence of the value of
several social interventions as a result
of the work that Professor Haslam has
described when we look at this exciting
new evidence as well as significant if
far from majority community practice I
believe we are nevertheless faced with a
serious question one hesitates to claim
a large trunked animal in the corner of
the salon but knowing how well this
style and philosophy of intervention
works for a variety of illnesses and
conditions why do we do so little of it
why for example is medicine almost
entirely individual even mental health
treatment oh we do have groups but
they're pretty far from social groups
and they're not usually overly endowed
with meaning we can see why acute care
focuses primarily on individuals but why
elder care why do we insist on saving
money by cutting staff and staff
training that could make this social
group work possible why do we so often
have leave social interventions to
volunteers or families and when it is so
challenging to get this right with
people who can afford quality care and
government-sanctioned settings how about
all the people some just old and many
many with mental illnesses who receive
only minimal care of any kind in the
community or who depend on charity or
who receive their absence of mental
health treatment only in prisons there
are even people who can't afford a
computer hard as that is to believe so
having learned from Professor Haslem's
excellent work several interventions
that improve both quality of life and
actual
health interventions that do not seem to
be particularly expensive interventions
which fit in with at least some streams
of community practice how do we make the
policy changes necessary to get more of
this happening and soon that is I
believe the question we need to put our
minds to if we are seriously committed
to social innovation we do have the
technology we know how to do this we now
have the evidence of impact outcomes
results we know that it works how do we
get the will to do what we ought to do
for and with our parents now our friends
and colleagues in a few years to say
nothing of all the ill marginalized and
disenfranchised people we probably don't
know as well does evidence ever inform
policy how long must venerable people
wait for what we know is a better way
kath is absolutely right what we need is
this ability this commitment to
translate into identity centered
policies to optimize benefits for
at-risk groups thank
you